so when I'm walking through Jerusalem
and you see and they say these are the
Muslim quarters this is where the
Muslims are allowed to live that doesn't
feel like a Bastion of freedom to me
it's very easy for us obviously to make
fun of MSNBC and to make fun of the
Hamas caucus and everything else but I'm
also noticing another problem in the in
the online pundit class of a series of
people who seemingly talk as if they
know everything but really don't know
anything related to the history so I
want to show you a clip from Candace
Owens podcast personally look I do not
want to make this about Candice
specifically but Ian you you clipped
this and it went viral and I think
people were sort of catching on to
something that is a wider problem so
personally I'm not making this about
Candice uh but but take a look at the at
the confusion here when people call it
you know this Bastion of Freedom or it's
just like America I that's not the sense
that I had when I was there and again we
had talked earlier on about how our own
experiences obviously color our opinions
and I grew up you know my grandparents
house my grandfather grew up in a
segregated South and so when I'm walking
through Jerusalem and you see and they
say these are the Muslim quarters this
is where the Muslims are allowed to live
that doesn't feel like a Bastion of
freedom to me um so I guess oh I don't
think it's where they're allowed to live
in Jerusalem I think it's that there are
there's an Armenian quarter it's not
saying the Armenians can only live here
it's that there are communities just
like there's a a Jewish community in in
Jersey here and there's a Muslim
Community in here I don't think you know
to my understanding it's not
restrictions within Israel proper of
where isra is where they I think it is
where they have I mean says with the
rabbi who was taking me around he said
these are the Muslim quarters so this is
where the
Muslims live but he didn't say anything
about legally saying they cannot live on
other places within Israel proper I mean
there's Israeli Arab citizens that have
full rights Israeli Arab I'm only
talking about Jerusalem so I haven't I
haven't been to Tel Aviv or anything
like that I'm I'm just talking about
particularly Jerusalem itself as a city
is has has a division in it where the
green line divides and there's East
Jerusalem that's maybe what he was
talking about not the Muslim quarter but
east Jerusalem um there's disputed
territory within the West Bank in East
Jerusalem that divides and therefore
they're under Palestinian Authority or
even other jurisdiction but um you know
that's that's that's a different
conversation as far as what those are
but Arabs within Israel if you go to
Israel people would be surprised to see
on every street sign Hebrew English and
Arabic you see a multicultural City so
I'm keep going a little bit because I'm
curious in your experience in Jus yeah I
know and maybe I'm misunderstanding it
but I think it's worth talking because I
I my understanding from the rabbi was
that this is where the Muslims have to
live in Jerusalem and it looked very
different from where you know the Jewish
people were living and that again that
could not be any fault of any person
other than this is how they take care of
their stuff and this is the way that we
take care of their stuff but you know it
was noticeably a lot dirtier it was
noticeably a lot darker um and it just
made me feel as a black American and
knowing my own history that this is not
this isn't freedom to me like if you
can't just decide like I want to but I
want to live on that street or I want to
live on this street but maybe I'm maybe
I'm wrong and it wasn't right they were
just all might Mis it might have been a
misunderstanding imagine if you went
into an inner city in the United States
and somebody told you this a
predominantly black neighborhood and you
said it looked more rundown would you
say that America's systemically racist
because of I a tour of it I wouldn't say
this is the black quarters probably or
this a black neighborhood but maybe
somebody in the group might
misunderstand that yeah you know maybe I
did yeah I was want to ask you about
that okay so again I don't want to make
this specifically about her but it
should be noted that when they talk
about Jerusalem and we were just there
six months ago and I I actually I said
to my guys right before we started we we
took a lot of video there and we'll show
something on Monday that explains how
these quarters work Israel didn't create
the Muslim quarter and the Jewish
quarter and the Armenian quarter and
everything else first off they largely
live in peace you can actually Jews
generally don't walk through the Muslim
quarter because you might get killed but
anyone can walk through the entrance in
in West Jerusalem but the point is these
these quarters have existed for
thousands of years it's Israel that has
opened up Jerusalem to be an
international City that everyone can
come to yeah I think that's a problem
with the General commentary class on
both sides is that we have a a a really
a business system in which you just are
paid to say things you're paid to have
thoughts um but it gets a little sticky
when we're talking about things with
very deep consequences like the Deep
levels of antisemitism we're seeing
exploding all over the world based on
really a conspiracy theory of
anti-Semitism and a conspiracy theory
about Israel and so for example
comparing um Jerusalem to the
segregation of Jim Crow era it it's
simply not true uh I'm not going to talk
about you know the motivations behind
that because you can't look inside
someone's heart but the fact say it's
not true but it has very deep and
dangerous consequences because then
people will continue to compare uh
modern day Israel to Jim Crow South to
Nazi Germany and that is the exact
propaganda that places like
organizations like Hamas and students
for justice in Palestine and all these
other groups are pushing they're
comparing Israel to racist fascist
apartheid regimes because that is their
entire excuse for all of the violence
that they then commit against
Jews